en forte hausse après les tragiques
attentats du 13 novembre une baisse du
don du sang a été enregistré trois mois
plus tard elle encourt une collectes
mobiles organisées en partenariat avec
la ville et l'établissement français du
don du sang est aussi là pour rappeler
l'importance de la mobilisation des
donneurs tout au long de l'année
une occasion pour rappeler à l'ensemble
des français enfin des habitants de la
france d'ailleurs que l'on du sang
c'était indispensable et que c'est
devaient être permanents il fallait pas
attendre des circonstances aussi
épouvantable pour donner son sang ce
n'était pas une publicité mais une bonne
relance pour le fait que le nom du sang
était indispensable pour pouvoir soigner
la forme de pathologie et pas que des
blessés en plus des sites fixes ouverts
dans le département trois collectes
mobiles sont organisées chaque année à
elancourt une façon d'attirer
l'attention sur le besoin mais aussi de
permettre les dons aux habitants qui ne
peuvent se déplacer si ça peut motiver
certaines personnes qui ne font pas à le
faire
c'est très bien moi après jeu dès que
j'ai l'occasion je donne n'était sur les
ailes donner son sang très rapidement
après les attentats parce que baffe
c'est la seule réponse qu'on pouvait
apporter un petit peu intelligente à ce
genre de ce genre de choses puis après
il faut le faire tout le temps
régulièrement entre chaque don un délai
de trois mois est nécessaire d'où
l'importance de renouveler les donneurs
l'objectif pour 2016 52 mille poches de
sang a prélevé un défi relevé en 2015
avec 55 mille poches récoltées dans le
département